I really am because you and I have not
only stand up in common mm-hmm but we
also are huge fans of soccer no he's a
man you fan do you guys know that we
just saw the documentary on Zlatan last
week yeah the best one it just basically
goes back and forth between his career
in IX and his last year in Malmo mm-hmm
so we like then when he was like 18 19
when he was just starting yeah it's
really good and how when he first got to
IAC's
there was so much pressure because they
spend spend so much money on him in that
first year it wasn't great oh yeah and
then in the second year he came alive
and it's a pretty good document if you
like you know soccer no or if you like
just sports in general you you realize
like you know how he's always jumping
from team to team to team and you
realize that it's because his whole life
he's he was raised by [ __ ] played
soccer like a gypsy yeah right and also
he at because I you know I've talked
about in this podcast the the the photo
with him in pk oh yeah yeah you know
that photo yeah you showed me I should I
know
so basically um a lot on ibrahimovic who
plays for men you used to play for
Barcelona and he was leaving Barcelona
and he was saying goodbye to draw PK
who's a defender he's still there who's
married to Shakira and they take a photo
of them basically [ __ ] that very
intimately intimately let me ask you a
question my friend for two straight
dudes you and I you and I let's you and
I were before you and I were in war in
war like we're in Vietnam
right okay and we saw the [ __ ] right I
mean we saw people die you know I got
shrapnel in my ass one night and your as
a brother you carry me back to the
foxhole and you just take the [ __ ]
shrapnel in my ass
one by one right first of all that's the
the Red Cross guys I wanted you do it
but the right but no I
this is what I would do if I think
there's gonna be some shrapnel going in
your house that I have to pick out hey
I'm jumping in front of the grenade in
your ass
again so and then I'll stop it in if it
gets in your ass yeah I'm going back to
base to say Bobby didn't make no because
you don't because you don't even know
why the struggles in my ass I don't know
why it's in you yes because the Vietcong
is attacking right and I bend over
because you're already [ __ ] me are
you already [ __ ] me right and that's
how no I'm not kidding but what I'm
saying is that if you and I are in war
for ten years and then we were like
leaving like going back to the States
and we're gonna separate right we would
give each other a pound a pound we
wouldn't do what is Lawton and it was it
was close very close right there fingers
weren't a yes so you're not and you were
you were denying that they were gay but
now what's your opinion
kalila well initially I was like look
they're European you know they get
touching or they play touch by the Lud
right but then now I have a real theory
in place oh yeah
so both Gerard piqué and Slaton have
been with her women for a long time but
both of their women are ten years
approximately ten years older than them
only women who are women are yeah so
slot tongs wife it's like 46 and Shakira
is about 37 so these are apks what like
a 29 28 or something like that anyways
my theory is this only older women would
really allow for a sexual fluidity in
their marriage meaning to say that I
think that only old it it comes with age
to kind of be a little bit more
understanding of your man's sexuality
let's suppose like they were both
bisexual I bet you those two women who
would be okay with it
like I didn't if in my 20s I wouldn't
want to be with a guy who was bisexual
but now that I'm in my 30s it wouldn't
bother me so Bobby's bisexuality does
not Bob that's probably [ __ ] what I
just what I said I'm not against it oh
yeah that makes some sense to me but you
guys are playing good now huh yeah say
we tired with Liverpool yeah I know but
that was still like
you know you thought I thought you guys
will lose you did yeah I did because it
was like what 85th minute yeah yeah and
then Slaton gets ahead at header right
tie is it and it shows the old men you
fighting spirit right
and then we almost kind of wanted yeah
you guys almost kind of want it and and
I thought that their goal was [ __ ]
there's a penalty yeah [ __ ]
yeah and Padma messed up they got lucky
and they score but I mean I'm just
saying that pogba I don't think who do
you think that that was a handball no I
don't think was intentional yes that's
how and that's how they hit the point
here yeah they want to say our goal was
offsides
yeah you know right and I was actually
rooting for you guys or you were yeah
because I want Liverpool to start losing
oh yeah because so you because they Pat
who where are you guys now we're for for
yeah but Man City did you see that game
peppers pep [ __ ] up Wow well I don't
know if I told you this on the podcast
he this is the worst personnel he's ever
had to coach at bar sir he had the best
in the league right at Bayern I had the
best in the league yeah he came to a
team that has no defenders and no
defensive midfielders and and and his
team his personnel are not the best
players in the league he has four good
players
yeah he has agüero agüero sterling
Debruyne and david silva yeah and so the
other sometimes your your quarry
european that's right that's how they
say I apologize I apologize okay am i
living in yeah
and my bad people right so yeah they're
team he's got a shitty team
no offense right you're right I mean you
think cliche and Sonia and those guys
are about to I just think even with
cliche and Sonia you have no defensive
midfielder right well you do but he's
he's out for like three games
fernandinho if i got a red card yeah and
then it's arty on monday and Johnstone's
is probably too young
yeah he should probably be a defensive
midfielder yeah cuz where is that other
part of the four or no he's no good no
or yeah but he lumbers sometimes that's
right it doesn't track bad doesn't track
back yeah any truck back on the davies
goal yeah my fans
listen to this podcast go we don't talk
about I'm just telling you I'm gonna
talk about what I want to talk about
let's [ __ ] talk about what I want to
talk about another [ __ ] edited
alright I'm just gonna do what I'm gonna
do
alright and I love everybody I want
people to have a good time right but I'm
no longer gonna have that in my head
just to I'm just I'm just venting from
my own soul I just can't believe
Leicester City is doing this shitty I
mean I guess you can't believe it but
then you sort of feel bad that you know
then you really believe that it was a
fluke it was a fluke but you when you
when you look how they play now you're
like goddamn renew you was a good coach
last year yeah and then you give him
credit for for the like it wasn't
impossible win and this is who they
really are
yeah when you have a dream attached to
something and and the whole country in
the world is praying for something to
happen
we kind of manifested them yeah right
mmm-hmm I really believe in
manifestations yeah me too
and so but now they won the league now
the rest of the world [ __ ] it what no
the regular people win right and now
they're just terrible
yeah not great and Jamie Vardy should
assign with Arsenal and you know you
know I had like some Irish dudes
on the podcast today and and and we we
realized something like I alleged yeah
yeah like where we're from Ireland yeah
but they they're in town yeah but are
they from Ireland or they're just
Norfolk from Ireland also there that
accident that we had accents yeah yeah
yeah and one of them was like like and
and somebody else said you said I don't
know who said like Wenger doesn't like
certain personalities on his side yeah
not anymore he used to like the tough
guys
yeah but the team is a little awesomes a
little soft and you guys could assign
Conte yeah and and Conte went to a team
that was 10 finale glass here as opposed
to a team that was you guys second and
in league last year yeah I wanker should
have pursued him more and had a better
chance at getting I mean that's what you
guys need
I know fangers made a lot of mistakes
yeah I mean he could have signed back in
the day even River [ __ ] or the club I
don't know but it was like old dudes at
all no but this is when you remember she
was young no this is like when he was 18
or 19 you know we could have signed him
and um also Alexi Sanchez's behavior
this weekend did you see that yeah but I
acts another else no friend of mine yeah
you know he's a gunner for life yeah me
too and uh he was like he was just upset
that he came out the game no no
something else we see this right now
tell me we're winning 4-0 mm-hmm
Danny Welbeck has been hurt for a very
long time as you know when somebody's
injured for that long and they get
healthy they need the playing time right
right so Vanga goes we're up for 0 I'm
gonna take the stars off mm-hmm and
Alexis Sanchez literally started almost
crying because he got substituted for a
friend of his who's a teammate who needs
to playing to playing time and then at
one point he's on the bench and he has
his jacket over his face and he's like
doesn't want the cameras to see him
because he got sucked it out it's so
dramatic and [ __ ] and [ __ ] dumb be a
[ __ ] man and be a good dude
all right now now that makes sense but
why did he do it though why was he being
dramatic because he's always like that
like if clays like that they're personal
yeah he's okay if that's passion sure
right but there's also there's a there's
a line right your question does make me
wonder like yeah like alright why is he
doing that yeah he's he's making it
uncomfortable for the [ __ ] team right
he makes it all about himself like he's
you know it's like all of a sudden now
all the newspapers cycle and the news is
all about him acting like a [ __ ] baby
right and it shouldn't have been about
that it should have been about how we
won 4-0 in how um Danny well because
healthy and be positive you have to be
able to argue to that it's that same
intense competitive spirit that makes
him the baby also makes him Alexi
Sanchez right no yes I think so I think
he's probably Fenger says that he's one
of the hardest-working he's always on
fear if the rest of your team like if
the members of the team like had the
passion that he had you guys would be
top of the table I don't know man
I think my guy keeps running man that's
that's now agility it's like it like I'm
Nigel II hit was it called strut
conditioning no nobody say this right
now
if I was on Arsenal's team the way I am
now trust me I will have the passion oh
no I figure if there was like a machine
that you can attach to me and Alexei and
who has more passion I think might even
be able to go above it
ya know it was in terms of passion
you've never 5mr passion that was my
nickname in high school my passion to
drop my eyes get all cheered up I
tremble yeah
have you played a ball sport ever in
your life yes [ __ ] I played ball for
[ __ ] alright tennis and you know I have
I was on the high school tennis team
I mean you're passionate now I don't
have the conditioning right so it's like
what if I believe Drew's just as
passionate
no really that scorpion kick enough said
[Music]